we live in the great state of what
Florida righta Ronda santis okay has
done a phenomenal job but obviously he's
being targeted so watch what's happening
with Florida insurance premium that
everybody is talking about Rob if you
can pull up the logo at the top so we
can see it's Newsweek so this is a
Newsweek zoom in a little bit more so
they can see it there you go Newsweek
magazine Florida residents flee State as
insurance premiums Skyrocket up to
900% this is a topic of discussion
across the country a lot of people right
now are trashing and bashing Florida and
the Santas let's go a little bit lower
on the numbers okay so for years now the
sunny vibrant state of a magnetic
destination for many Americans a
phenomenon which has been driving up
demand for housing especially during the
pandemic as well as home prices but
while Florida was the number one state
in the country that people moved to in
2022 it was also the number one with the
highest number of residents wanting to
relocate according to Self Storage
according to the US Census Bureau an
estimated 275,000 people left Florida in
2022 nearly 23,000 people every month
most according to the be relocated to
places like Georgia 47,000 North
Carolina 42,000 Tennessee 36,000 South
Carolina 31,000 Texas 30,000 somebody
would read this article say oh my God
Florida is losing it all go L go L the
part about 27 $1,700 versus 4 right
there homeowners insurance premium have
tripled in the state of uh in the past
five years with residents currently
paying on average of $4,200 per year the
national average is $1,700 by the way
this is an accurate number that they're
talking about some insurance premiums
have risen about nine times what they
were in 2022 Oscar chief executive of
MSI Insurance to W wsa Wall Street
Journal with multi-million dollar homes
generating premiums costing as much as
$600,000 a year I know on what these
numbers are because I'm kind of going
through this however here's what I want
you to do if you go to the top where it
says how many people have
left the state of uh uh uh what do you
call it the State of Florida when you
read that that article what is your
immediate reaction what do you say you
say what oh my God oh my gosh I'm being
spun 23,000 people are leaving Florida I
thought they were moving to Florida is
terrible I guess the other news was
wrong yeah and then and then you
actually go to the US sensus Bureau to
verify see this number and then this is
what US Census Bureau says Rob I just
texted it have it it's called fact check
pull this up no but the part is that
media not telling the entire information
confuses people okay totally confuses
people this article is telling you oh
Florida's like California now people are
leaving Florida people are leav in
Florida pull up the pull up the article
I just sent you Rob if you could uh uh
it's in the link this is by the way the
level of manipulation on how they're
targeting the Ronda listen I called that
Ronda santis a lot I'm not sitting here
saying I'm a you know 100% supportive of
everything he does their Camp probably
wouldn't look at pbd podcast as a pro
Ronda santis Camp no but here when
you're targeting a guy that's done a
phenomenal job for a state the entire
story needs to be told go all the way to
the bottom to look okay the domestic net
migration by state that's the number the
number you're looking for is what net
migration go all the way to the down
that it gives you the plus minus keep
right there right there that's the
number look at this three the number one
state in 2022 net migration is what 318
855 you know what this means you know
the number Newsweek says it's 275 yeah
that means if 275 left you know how many
came here's what this means it's called
275 plus 318 here we go 600,000 here we
come
593 th000 moved here that's 50k a month
but 23 chose to leave the net is 318
that's why you always look at the
domestic net migration what's number two
by a mile another great State Texas 231
then it's the Carolinas then Tennessee
Georgia Arizona Idaho what do you notice
there red states are attracting people
now go to the bottom who do you think's
all the way at the bottom by the way go
all the way to the bottom all the way to
the bottom california-
343 holy minus 3 then it's two New
York then it's two Illinois then it's
two Jersey then it's Massachusetts blue
blue blue blue blue by the way New York
where the news week is located you know
what you and I have in common Tom let me
tell you what you and I have in common I
want you to think about if a man okay
had the privilege okay the satisfaction
of having been with Marilyn Monroe
elizabth Taylor and Sophia Lauren he can
expand and speak on their different
styles of course in the bedroom yes
Marilyn mono was like this Sophia Lauren
liked the pillow like this you know
Elizabeth Taylor liked XYZ toys whatever
you can kind of expand on that right all
right so check this out I lived in
California for 20 20 something years I
lived in Texas for five plus years I've
been in Florida now nearly three years
January it'll be three years that we've
been here so I know California I know
New York I know Texas Texas phenomenal
place to raise a family to have your
business it's an incredible Place some
of the places they're trying to turn
blue Austin's getting blue the
homelessness problem in Austin's a real
problem California is still a show
okay people are leaving companies are
leaving parents are leaving they're sick
of what's going on in California and
when you look at the great state of
Florida what do they keep doing they
keep attracting they keep standing up do
you know what the the scientist just
said he said if Biden chooses to take
refugees from Gaza he says you know how
many people can come to Florida this is
how many we're going to take this is how
many we're going to take if that offends
you Florida's not the state for you I
highly recommend you go to California
when these people are sitting there
saying I feel uncomfortable my kid not
being able to transition the Great in
the State of Florida you know what I
tell him California is a great spot for
you beautiful keep going there and and
remember when we were in California I
don't know if you you were with us right
when went to to the debate did you go
you didn't go to R I wasn't in C we had
a big debate at Yoshinoya with this one
guy that pulled up to me saying I love
your content the only thing I don't like
about you is the fact that you bash
California we had a 30-minute I said sit
down let's have a conversation at 11:30
at Yoshinoya okay that we're having this
don't ask us why we go to Yoshino I
secretly love yoso yes takes me back to
being 14 WIS are great yeah what's
what's the moral of the story here's a
moral of the story when people show you
numbers and data unpack the numbers to
see really what's going on when I saw
this numbers you know what I noticed
watch what happened here you know what
insurance company just left the state of
Florida what insurance company just
announced they're leaving the State of
Florida a company called Farmers what
they left the state of Florida so now
everybody's saying Farmers left the
state of Florida yeah they also don't do
business in Hawaii in Maine in New
Hampshire any of the what do you call it
co
and even in California they're regulated
right but this article no one looks up
and sees what other places Farmers left
they left this and here's what people
don't realize you know who's the first
person that signed the UN agreement to
make more companies follow the ESG
environmental social governance you know
who was the first company that signed it
who it was Farmers Oh weird and you know
what jimy petronis called Farmers the
budlight of insurance oh they're about
to be the budlight of insurance and he
Bush of insurance by the way the reason
why when I didn't even have plans of
going into this story when you guys
talked about Victoria Secret
automatically I saw what's going on here
in the State of Florida I thought we
have to talk about it Tom do you any any
thoughts on what's going on here with
Florida wow Farmers so it's we are
leaving that's right no it's it's it's
very simple Jimmy petronus is right and
Jimmy petronus by the way he is the
basically the CFO of the State of
Florida and he's responsible for
economic forecast into making it
attractive environment understanding
regulation because you know we have
property taxes here we have things you
got to pay for fire trucks and police
somehow and we don't have a state income
tax and so he is out there basically
just putting companies on notice that if
you guess what if you want to come here
and you want to want to play right guess
what I got a great economy for you I got
a lot of people here and you can do what
you want you want to go be a little bit
weird and then you want to get mad and
leave take your marbles and go home
because there are other people here that
want to serve the people of Florida so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right
here